so so question how many bodies is Too
Many Bodies how many bodies is Too Many
Bodies
damn I have to give a Hardline
responsible you could say plus or minus
like you know roughly
I think
the age I'm at now
mid to late 20s
I think anything in the in London
because everyone will lie about the body
count I know where the people are on in
school below 10 is good 10 to 15. is
okay and then below 20 is like
you wouldn't agree with it but you'd
accept it because I've come to realize
having done numbers myself
[Music]
so many people lie that is is yeah and
especially I've got one thing I've come
to the realization as well is that cool
say at one point I was chopping out and
going through but the reality is
is these same women were probably
getting chopped out by guys like me who
were just time wasters so probably from
what I'm attracted to is like Echo
Chambers like I could go to for that
nerdy girl who plays chess and her body
count probably below three but then like
if I tried to put my thumb in a bum she
might be like whoa what's going on so
what's that Jesus
or she might not she might be on she
might she might be on it she might be on
it you know yeah
what about what about you
um I'd say below 10. yeah
um
it's a wife yeah oh it's a wife yeah um
yeah I'm gonna say below 10.
but no question part of it what I say to
demanding yeah I find with a lot of men
a lot of men think they're the guy in it
I'm not saying you might not the guy but
a lot of men will say mad numbers like
R5 because I've slept with tent and part
of it is the insecurity of that weight
if she's on the same numbers at me it's
the realization that maybe they're not
the guy
so do you think that plays into it as
well because I know a bag of man that I
slept with like say less than 10 and
they're like no I have to be like free
but that's like a [__] in their
masculinity what do you man think on
that
wait could you just reframe that in like
a simpler context like because I that
was so long-winded but I kind of get
what you're talking about what I'm
trying to say is like do you think that
that is based on that figure alone or is
it any way related to yours
oh okay yeah I think it's related but
it's more like
I'm assuming you okay would I be
correcting saying you wouldn't be with
someone that slept with more people than
you yeah am I correct in saying that
correct so do you think say I don't know
what if he could say if it would say a
hundred yeah do you think that figure
would be higher
yes yeah yeah that's what I find with a
lot of man is like a lot of men they
wouldn't go for someone who's near them
because a lot of men they think they're
the guy and the fact that a woman an
attractive woman that slept with near
the same amount of bodies as you maybe
you're not as special as you think
um my my kind of uh dictation on numbers
is based on like math I'm thinking all
right under 10 or under single digits
where she's probably got some way to
kind of pair bond with me at a point
where it's not a case where her whole
pair bonding process is gone she she's
less likely to be Alpha widowed and like
I don't and I don't know at what level
she's been Alpha widowed like I might
say oh I have Alpha widowed a girl yeah
but then the guy that avoided her is on
a next thing but one thing I'll say in
this London yeah
the only way to really find that is to
find girls with long-term relationship
if that's what you value because say
we're you're around mid-20s say you
really lose lose your virginity at say
16 which is the average in this country
that most girls lose it at yeah if you
do one a year for
up to the age of now that's 10. but the
reality is we know what girls get onto
when they find their sexuality in terms
of in uni Etc and I just know so many
girls because I had a lot of female
friends so many women just like and they
just play the game so it's like well say
this is too much but the reality is you
don't even really know I mean ignorance
is bliss if you're not
but I think you also want someone with
like similar morals to you I guess
especially if if that's what they were
doing at Uni
you can't just wipe out the aspect of
your personality they might be more
likely to cheat later on if yeah no I
agree I agree if you're more promiscuous
you're probably more likely to be well I
think that's why guys stay younger yeah
but less baggage less yeah less bodies
less stress and like it's
one thing that I I said this one
um one thing that I kind of do when day
Indigo I literally look at her friends
I'll be like birds are the same feathers
plot together oh 100 so so more time if
a girl's like hiding her promiscuity
I'll literally look at her friends how
are her friends moving and like usually
she's got two or three her friends and
I'm like oh so this is what you guys are
on
and now you're showing me a version that
doesn't look anything like your friends
yeah 100 I I won't even test the waters
because I'll know that I she'll she'll
pull a fast one on me would you say it
though because I see what you're saying
but I just think men have a lot to lose
nowadays when it comes to like paternity
flop fraud you know
um paternity fraud they said [__]
holdery and divorce grape is a grim
reality for men cuckold like wait
where's his [__] holding um that's quite
mad so is Russell Wilson like well sort
of when you think about it like because
he he's a [__]
don't get me wrong like he's very
respectable and like all these
accomplish he's like a one percent dude
but it's it's sad when you see a one
percent dude wife a hoe it's just like
you could yeah it's not like I didn't
have options as well why is she a hoe
because she I mean she dated like every
rapper before and she don't respect him
as well yeah and and if you watch uh
could you pull up the video could you
pull up a video of the video of her on
top of the car because I think that that
would be a good one to show I thought
she said the goodies stayed in the jaw
I'm a slag and I love [__] never
the rule was
um Sierra
I'm gonna pull it out but basically like
the the the idea is like can you turn a
hoe into a housewife
and and the thing is like your habits
are who you are so if a girl's been
doing something for 10 years
like is she gonna magically stop one day
probably not
it's the same thing with the guy if he's
cheated in every single relationship
he's been in he's probably going to
cheat on you too
and she people can change
yeah
but I think the the actions of
um either being a hoe like what comes
with it it may manifest in different
areas you may not go out and do the
things but it may
May how do I explain it
it can it can be in different areas of
her life so if even if guys in with
cheating if they don't if they say okay
I'm not going to cheat on my wife they
don't fix it if they don't work on it
and change it it can manifest in
different ways it may not be in cheating
but it may not it may be in different
areas and work and other relationships
they may be just dodgy in however they
approach different things it shall send
it to you in the DMs I got you
um I just found it uh